[Music]
yeah you showed a sequence of successive
universes one after the other I can see
how the sequence proceeds but I mean the
the obvious question is where does it
all start
I mean and how is that a significant
event that starts whether philosophy
here although in detail completely
different it's like the old steady state
model that was one of the reasons you
know when you go back and you think of
what Newton thought to thought they were
very happy with the universe which was
there all the time you see and there
wasn't a beginning in fact Einstein
fought against when the metro tried to
convince him that there really was this
what we now call a BIGBANG origin he
didn't like the idea at all but but he
had to be converted to it by the
equations seem to tell you that you
can't get away with it otherwise and
then if then people got accustomed to
the Big Bang there or not just being
there you see I'm claiming it is there
but it's not the beginning so the
argument as as you say is is like well
where did it come from well it came from
the one before where did that come from
one before I I once I had to give a talk
about this in in the Vatican and I was
rather nervous about what they would say
you see because LeMay sure was a was a
priest and he took a kind of religious
tone you see if you believe in the Big
Bang Theory you've got to believe that
God was there first to make it if you
believed in the steady-state model it
was all right not to have a god you see
so that got messed up the argument
rather than what you should do is look
at the data and all that stuff so it's
the same argument there doesn't have to
be a beginning it was just always there
but when I was in the Vatican I thought
I was going to be pounced on by these
people you see they say no no no no they
took what from my point of view is the
correct answer
I don't you should say from their point
of view the correct answer no grant God
created the whole thing you see well I
suppose he could do that too
I don't think it's a religious point you
see I think it's kind of been all there
for all time
Einstein tried to study my model which
was supposed to be stationary for all
time Newton thought that similar sort of
thing he thought if there was a bit
advance the instability God could come
in and fix it up again and let it keep
going you see so this seems to be a view
that other people have held before quite
happily that there could have been an
eternal universe and this is just a
little more complicated version of an
eternal universe thank you sorry I
should other questions come in thank you
it's great talk I'm not sure if if I
have fully understand it I understood
what you said but are you saying that
the universe is therefore not expanding
yeah and does that then remove the need
for a dark energy no I'm accepting no
you probably weren't here at the
previous discussion we had no I'm taking
the view that what people call dark
energy is what Einstein introduced in
1917 for the wrong reason the
cosmological constant and that is a way
of modifying Einstein's original
equations it's about the only way you
can do it without wrecking them so it
was a good idea and put in for the wrong
reason when he only originally
introduced it he claimed it was his
worst blunder but in fact it probably
seems to be true I mean there's still
argument about them but it's pretty
clear that there was something going on
which looks like the cosmological
constant now I've forgotten your
question sorry yes
the fact that you're showing these
repeated universes over eons as
effectively cylinders if that's intended
to be a literal interpretation
it's a conformal interpretation I think
when you have mass around then you've
jolly well got to have the expansion you
see those then you can measure distances
and once you can measure the distances
then okay it's expanding it's only here
I claim when you can't measure distances
when there's no mass around then it
becomes in determined
how big it is in a certain sense the
universe forgets how big it is that's
the sort of anthropomorphic way of
saying it but I'm saying that the scale
becomes and felt by the universe because
there's nothing which gives you a scale
the mass is not there so big and small
become physically equivalent I'm so
sorry if I could just expand that
further are you saying that it would
have expanded it had to expand to get to
that point where scale ceases to be
relevant well when there's mass around
and it has to come in you know it's
something to do with eggs particles and
so on when it comes down the temperature
comes down below the Higgs temperature
and thinks that's a particle physics
question right and according to that the
mass will coming in to a certain point
before that you have a situation where
the scale of the universe is not
determined and so the idea is in the
future it's not determined in the
beginning it's not determined so I have
the freedom to match them up and the
idea is that the equation you've got to
go into equation C and make it work and
you can make it work there are some
questions that still they're still
around about that but it's something you
can make sense of yes the dark energy I
don't like the term because it's neither
dark nor energy but apart from that it's
it's what I call what people used to
call the cosmological constant I mean it
might be not that but it's completely
consistent with that at the moment this
is so that has to be there because this
makes infinity to be the right shape so
to say it doesn't work otherwise if you
didn't have it this model would not work
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at AI TV
you